My name is upright This is also reversed here
oh wow Record is tomato Swiss
* Based on English
[Music] It's
fun
[Music]
Really
Thank you
Hee-suk Lee Shave
Chunk If you're intelligent enough to
mask or come across 100
side dishes uh or something like this  80,000 ozone does not have
9 power, so we stay about 1
[Music]
5 Well
, there will of course be some influence on the people who were actually caught and their families or people involved,
so as an actor,
uh, now I have moral responsibilities one after another 5
And again, in this drama,
we can't give a perfect answer, and we can't give
a perfect answer.
[Music]
Being there is my own
charm Even though I’m young, I
go into worship, go into worship, feel intern, Shanghai or something like this,
Zhuge’s game, tactile sense will come to me,
I’m sensitive to plans.
co
[Music] All
my life, I'm a weird person, and I think that I'm
different from other people, it's my individual
fault, and I'm not good at getting along with other people.
I've lived my life thinking like this.
In some ways, I
think I know a little bit about the concept contrast, and
I explained myself.
4 Language also has wealth, so I don't feel like it's non-transferable.
[Music]